talk to us a little bit about what dog
fencer geofencing is how does it work I
suspect some of the drone manufacturers
are cringing at our use of dog fence it
is a good analogy essentially you know
these drones now have a lot of computing
power and if they're connected to GPS
they know very precisely where they are
and so the drone manufacturers have set
up no-fly zones all around the country
you know chiefly around airports and
that but also say the White House
security sites like that and the GPS
knows where it is and so it
automatically keeps them outside of
those areas Alan what are the chant the
challenges then with geo fencing well
I'm if everybody uses it it's great but
the problem is we have probably hundreds
of thousands perhaps as many as a
million drones already out there just in
the u.s. some of those people won't
update their software or they're
incompatible with this system so it
won't work for them you know if the if
they're going to mandate it that would
take writing new regulations that could
take 23 years and going down the road we
also know that these things are
potentially vulnerable to hacking and
other sorts of patches that allow people
to fly in areas where they're not
allowed to so it's not a perfect
solution at all